Yesterday, during the press briefing of
a White House press secretary, Jen Psaki,
there was a clarification about Joe
Biden's tax plan when Joe Biden said
nobody earning under four hundred thousand
dollars a year will see an increase in taxes.
Did Joe Biden mean individuals earning up to
400 K or did Joe Biden mean households earning
up to four hundred K? During yesterday's
press briefing, Jen Psaki clarified
that it means households that is different than
four hundred thousand dollars per person. It's
four hundred thousand dollars per household.
And within moments on Fox News, right wing host
Charles Payne, as well as Republican Senator Chuck
Grassley, we're saying, look, look, we told you
Joe Biden is coming for middle income people.
Take a look at this clip. So what are we doing?
The exact opposite way. We know taxes were
promised and elections have consequences. But I
don't think anyone thought that the president,
president President Biden was talking about
household making. Four hundred thousand. I always
tell people, Senator, be careful when you pick up
the torching of pitchforks. Sooner or later
you might get. Up in front of your own house,
the middle income people of this country are smart
enough to know that when they hear a politician
or even the president of United States say that
only high income people, the very wealthiest,
are going pay the tax, they know better, if you
go there, you're going to eventually end up paying
taxes on middle income people.
So there are two relevant parts here. First is,
is 400000 dollars as a household income? Is that
middle income? That's the first question. The
second question is, are these the folks we should
be targeting for higher taxes? So when you say
400000 for a household, that could be two people
making two hundred K each, that could be someone
makes one seventy five and someone makes 25. Could
be, you know, three fifty and fifty total. Four
hundred thousand. That puts you in the top two
percent of households in the United States. So by
definition you're not in the middle. If you're
in the top two percent now, you could say, well,
you're in the middle like, you know, anything
that goes down to the second percentile and up
to the 90th counts middle. And then you've got two
percent of people that are poor and two percent
of people that are rich. I don't think most
people would imagine that the meat of the curve
is the middle 98 percent, for example,
or the middle 96 percent. By definition,
if you're in the top two percent, you're not in
the middle income. Now, you can go and look at
this for yourself. If you go to dequeue. Why D.J.
Dotcom? You can type in any household income. If
you type in four hundred thousand, for example,
you will see you're in the 90th percentile, the
top to get into the top two percent. This is 20
19 data to get into the top two percent. You had
to make as a household three hundred and eighty
seven thousand dollars. It's a little higher now,
probably because of inflation. It's right around
four hundred thousand a year. Puts you in the top
two percent. Now, the second part is actually more
interesting to me. You can like they're just wrong
that four hundred K is middle income. You're in
the top two percent. The more interesting part
is you can absolutely make the case that we should
be targeting not people who as individuals might
only make two hundred thousand as part of a four
hundred thousand dollar household. You should be
looking at people that are making five million
a year, 20 million a year, 200 million a year,
the billionaires that there's so much more meat
on the bone there that you shouldn't even include
four hundred thousand dollar households right now.
Now, that is a valid argument in the sense that
you're not denying reality. You're not saying four
hundred KS middle income. No, 400 K still in the
top two percent, but you should be targeting the
top one percent or the top zero point five percent
or the top zero point two percent. Four hundred
thousand dollars is a lot of money in any city,
but four hundred thousand in Manhattan with
three kids is nowhere near the same as four
hundred thousand dollars as a couple with no
kids in Alabama. So you just open this up to
more debate potentially if you make this about ten
million a year and up or 20 million a year and up,
there's no debate in any city. Maybe if you
have a thousand kids. Right. But but in any
city with one, two, three, four kids, that's a
ton of money anywhere. Maybe you start there.
And that is a different discussion and one that
certainly could be had. But there is no way to say
Biden's coming for the middle class. By
starting tax increases at four hundred
thousand dollars, it's just look
at a bell curve, it's not the case.
And by the way, there's one other hypocrisy here.
Charles Payne and Chuck Grassley talking about
middle income people making four hundred thousand
dollars, but a 15 dollar minimum wage is too much.
That's just another level of how everything
is just political posturing. None of this is
none of this is honest or they're really
that dumb. You decide which it is. I think
that it's that they're not honest. We'll
have more coverage of this on our Instagram
at David Pakman show and find my latest pastry
hall by following me on Instagram at David Pakman.